this is a story from Fox Business Apple
restricts airdrop file sharing in China
that protests have been used you know
what the timeline is under the latest
software update iOS 16.1.1 iPhone owners
in China can only use airdrop to receive
files images and videos from none other
non-contacts for 10 minutes according to
nine to five Mac
protests I intensified in China after
fire at Residential Building in the
western city of Europe left 10 people
dead uh until they welded the doors yeah
once that 10 minute window lapses
airdrop shifts back to contacts only
automatically
is that 10 minutes period or 10 minutes
at a time look at the power
10 minutes at a time meaning you have a
break it's like 10 minutes you can't do
another one huh so if I'm sitting there
like airdropping juice like what
happened look what happened look what
happened look what happened no no no
every 10 minutes every 10 minutes
prevents things from going viral and
other people seeing it I mean so listen
China's showing the game to its people
in China and photoshopping and and
editing sites that's showing people not
wearing masks at the freaking world cup
World Cup so people have to really
realize what's going on with this
country they don't believe in what you
and I believe in and when I say you and
I I don't mean you and I politically 95
of people the way you live your life
China's government doesn't believe you
ought to live your life the way you're
living your life you don't share common
values and principles they don't think
highly of us they don't think we're the
freedom and all that stuff that we stand
for and we fight for they don't they
don't stand for that stuff well the
government of China certainly believes
in capitalism but they rule their people
under the you know the banner of
Communism but they they they love making
money and gaining power over the
financial gains they've given not only
from America but from all over the world
so uh you know you talk about the shadow
Banner you got of on Tick Tock I mean
I've got it on Facebook before they took
me down and that's what they do I mean
they all said I was getting a million
views and it's down to 500 then it was
down a hundred thousand is down to 50. I
mean it was just like you could see it
happening right before my eyes and I'm
going wow so so much for freedom of
speech and I think we've never had total
freedom of speech in this country anyway
it's just gotten worse yeah I I don't
know if it happened to us on any other I
think I've not I've I myself can't say
any of that has happened on any other
apps personally except for tick tock I I
see everything else was about competing
and I know what has happened to other
people and I know a lot of people like
yourself that stuff was taken down
viewership went down etc etc but I
haven't seen it happen with us even
YouTube Some people are like well Pat
let me tell you your Shadow band on
Twitter on YouTube I don't agree I don't
think it is I think we have to fight in
the marketplace to get the message out
there I'm very confident competing with
other people on YouTube totally get it
our content's got to get better we got
to get better but with Tick Tock
comparing to other apps it's very
obvious that there's one word you can
use with Tick Tock and you cannot
criticize China on Tick Tock you just
can't you know how they say uh the pen
is mightier than the sword right well
these days social media is the ultimate
pen right I mean that's where you can
express anything you want to say
thoughts emojis memes videos you know
all that I had a a very enlightening
experience at this Freedom Forum Gary
Kasparov greatest Showman player ever
spoke at the Vault a year ago he invited
me down to the freedom forum and at the
freedom Forum it's all just massive
Freedom Advocates right from all over
the world you know China Chinese uyghurs
and uh you know Iranian uh the lady
forgive me her name with the hair the
one who's uh everywhere these days just
just complete Advocates of freedom and
uh the the most poignant example was
um they set up a like a booth like a
massive Booth probably the size of this
room and they called it the firewall
Cafe and basically
um it's sort of exposed what
the Chinese narrative like if you type
something like let's do an example right
now in Google if you type in uh she
president XI and Winnie the Pooh right
because people say he kind of looks like
that whatever this will pop up right I
don't know if you can if you can uh see
that just stupid images right like have
you even put in Trump you know images
will pop up but in this Chinese firewall
the firewall Cafe if you put that in
into the internet in China no images of
Winnie the Pooh will show up whatsoever
so the way that they just basically
segregate any type of content that would
be alarming or or of anything of
disinformation or anything against the
narrative they show it side by side at
this firewall Cafe and for the first
time I'm like oh wow this is what
America is as much as there's Shadow
Banning and all that in China it's
completely blocked and we're seeing
what's happening now with these riots
and protests and I I don't know where
that is nothing they did in the Top Gun
movie right they made it they Tom Cruise
had a jacket on they had the Taiwan flat
or something it was correct there was a
flag that they disagreed with they had
to go through every single frame and
remove it before they will let the movie
out because they're bowing down what
China is telling them to do because
China owns I think basically half the
movie theaters in America too but that's
a big market for American movies so you
see that the Chinese protests right now
they're they're just holding up a white
piece of paper right like you've seen
this it's just a blank so they can't
sheet of paper right what what is the
significance of that do you know what
that is exactly well they can't write
anything that's against the government
so they just pulled it up as a sign of
saying we are against the government
what do your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody